the texas legislature will debate a bill
this week that would force
transgender students to compete on sport
teams that match their assigned genders
at birth
now this is one of several measures
under consideration in texas
and it's part of a broader trend across
the country the human rights campaign
which advocates for which advocates
rather for lgbtq rights says at least
119 anti-transgender bills
have been introduced in state
legislatures this year alone
tennessee's governor signed three of
those bills into law last week
maria villarreal spoke to a family in
dallas caught in the middle
of this fight
at home the gonzalo sisters are often
fierce competitors
but over the last few years they've
teamed up to fight politicians
pushing anti-transgender bills i say
they shouldn't worry about
me and how my life is i think they
should just worry about their own lives
and move on
eleven-year-old libby is a transgender
girl hello my name is cecilia i'm from
dallas texas
and that's eight-year-old cecilia
defending her sister
at a recent health committee hearing at
the austin state capitol
i wouldn't change anything about her
because she's my sister and i love her
why did you decide to do that because
and
she wouldn't want to then she wouldn't
get to be able to be herself
and she wouldn't it's like she wouldn't
be happy for the rest of her life
the family is advocating against a
health care bill in texas
that targets parents who agree to
transgender affirming care
a recent pbs newshour npr marist poll
found that most americans republicans
and democrats
do not support bills that prohibit
transition-related medical care
still legislatures across the u.s have
introduced what advocates say
is a record wave of bills targeting the
transgender community
there are so many people that don't know
or don't know that they know
transgender individuals so it's so much
easier to demonize people that you
don't know you think you guys are being
used almost as pawns then
we're a hundred percent being used as
pawns they are inviting people to debate
whether or not our children have a right
to exist
whether or not they have a right to
public spaces whether or not they have a
right to
health care that they deserve playing
sports
loving parents texas lawmaker and
physician don buckingham
co-sponsored a bill that would bar
transgender athletes from competing on
girls sports teams
if you have a little girl and she
dreamed of whether it was a district
championship or a state championship
and then it was taken by somebody who
just had a physiologic advantage from
birth because they were born a male it's
just not fair to our little girls
none of the anti-transgender bills have
passed
yet but the texas session ends on may
31st
they think that our parents supporting
us
is child abusing when they're literally
telling us that we can't
be who we are and who are you
libby i'm libby for cbs this morning
mira viarial dallas texas
you go libby i think that says it all
i'm libby exactly that's who i am
exactly it's 2021 yeah